It's Rouis!
The lead in Adler?
He's handsome both on and off stage.
His movements, his voice, his gaze.
Rouis must be aware of
what he's projecting every minute.
He's just a year older,
but he's the star of our club
and holds power at school.
What are you staring at?
Is being rude a wolf's habit?
You're the pup from the art department.
Perfect timing. I have a favor to ask.
Follow me.
Okay.
This is just foolish.
I'll let you off the hook.
You'll be protected
for the rest of your life.
What are you staring at?
Showing your fangs to avoid a fight?
Excuse me.
Still, you seem like you have
a good understanding.
Come.
We're sneaking into the auditorium tonight
to give Zoe a rehearsal.
But if the school finds out...
That's why I need you to keep watch.
You're not going to refuse
and act like a hero, are you?
That's too bad.
If I promised you to give you my leg,
you'd drool and accept my proposal,
wouldn't you?
You're a wolf.
Act like one and give yourself
some prestige.
Who the hell are you?
Just because you're bigger than me,
you thought you could beat me?
Of course not.
Oh, dear!
Being a carnivore is not so easy, is it?
So cool!
Personality doesn't always match power.
Well, well, here is a star actor,
You must be busy,
since you're aiming for the next Beastar.
Have you ever thought
about why we need a Beastar in this world?
Get over your jealousy
and get yourself straightened out.
-Go wash your fangs with soap!
-Yeah!
Get lost!
Let's get outta here.
That's enough. Let's go.
Shut up!
Everyone, please go back to your meal.
Did I pay you back for last night?
That...
was nothing.
Thank you very much, Rouis.
If you weren't--
You had to act like a loser, right?
How long will you fake your personality?
It seems like you're a worse wolf
than I thought.
In the end, I'm one of the preys.
Excuse me.
-I...
-No matter how hard I try...
I'll never be a predator.
I've told you to knock.
I'm sorry. I did, but you didn't answer.
So I got worried.
What do you want?
I wanted to do a final check
on tomorrow's lighting.
That was you?
During the rehearsal, I took more time
to lower the light for the last scene.
I noticed.
Which was better for you?
Since it's the last scene,
I personally think
we should emphasize the afterglow.
Well, I don't know.
You fidget a lot when you talk.
-Gosh.
-I'm sorry.
I cut my claws often,
but they grow sharp again the next day.
Are you saying you can't do anything
about your aggressive nature?
That you're bothered by
your undeniable aggressive nature?
I've always wanted to ask you this.
Why don't you take responsibility
for your own strength?
Show it to me,
rather than holding it back.
Go ahead, show me your fangs.
What are you saying, Rouis?
It's against the law for a carnivore
to show his fangs to an herbivore--
Don't just call me an herbivore!
Don't be so sneaky.
A large carnivore like you is
what I loathe the most.
Stop acting cool
and be real for once.
Bite, Legoshi.
Bite me!
I'm... sorry.
Sorry, I talked too much.
I'll come back later.
It's warm...
Don't challenge me again, okay?
I am the hero.
Let me finish you off in style!
Looks like you are having so much fun.
Sorry, but I need you to play a villain.
I know who you really are!
I'll show you who the real Reaper is.
Legoshi, leave the rest to me.
Don't let the audience see your back.
Leave, if you are not determined.
Don't worry. You are right.
Rouis' skinny arm said to me,
"Come on. Get up."
The applause doesn't stop.
I wonder what they think
about this performance.